uh i would be um absolutely berated on
the internet if i didn't take the time
while i had you to talk a little bit
about digital currencies
uh you spend all day dealing with large
banks
bank customers kind of fit financial
technology
what have you seen from a viability
standpoint whether it's
you know a u.s digital dollar a digital
euro type thing so kind of a central
bank back digital currency
um there's the private currencies like
the libras that have been kind of thrown
out there's ideas
uh or even into the cryptocurrencies um
like the bitcoins and things like that
is there conversation about that and
kind of the world that you operate in
is it people are aware of it they don't
really care and don't talk about
it just give us an idea of kind of what
you've seen so far on the ground
yeah in my simple world um
businesses aren't asking i'm a really
simple person
at hyperwallet you know we were all
about
enabling different sorts of you know
payee directed if you wanted to
companies sending you 300 if you want to
have that direct deposit in your bank
cool you can do that under your control
if you want to pick up cash at western
union
cool you can do that under your control
so
when digital currencies in bitcoin
ethereum first came out i mean
i was and still like fangirl just
because the technology the prospect of
it
so i really thought that hyperwallet
ourselves should become an
end point um but this is going back to
our beginning this is after 2012 when
we're quote unquote a real company that
was making real money
um so not just a bunch of engineers
building the next
cool thing so i actually went to my head
of development i said i think that we
should become an endpoint at least on
ripple because it's you know
it's um you know in the cool kids club
it's bank last strike
um we went out and serviced our
customers and they were like
okay we have no interest in it um
so fast forward to now where i am at
five span i'm trying to build
applications that you know move the
peanut forward a little bit
for end customers and to be honest
i'm not excited about digital currency
for
you know b2b payments um
i've never thought that the rails were
the problem
it's always been the end points and
those consumptive applications
so i fundamentally don't think the world
needs another
payment rail um you know taking aside
the
political view of unstable currencies
and bad governments and everything else
where i'm most excited about distributed
ledger technology
is around things like
taking massive costs out of regulatory
burdens
um doing things like encrypting your kyc
file on a customer as a bank putting
that on some like ethereum like
whatever whatever chain you want and
then having you know only permission
and you know who's opening that little
secret package and why
um to me this can take enormous cost
and operational burden out of things
like sending a wire
from the united states to
thailand where a bank today has to have
you know a direct correspondent
relationship it's slow it's horrible
imagine
if you could just put this delivery
request
onto an ethereum onto some blockchain
any any delivery point in thailand can
pick it up and say yes i'm going to
deliver this money to this
you know end point if and only if i get
a regulatory hit
meaning like the thai regulator says
whoa whoa that's on
my kyb you know watch list then i'll
pick up this package unencrypt it you'll
know about it the customer will know
about it
and the purpose of us accessing this
data will be known
so long-winded explanation but that's
what i'm most excited about in financial
services
for blockchains and distributed ledgers
how far away are we from that
um there's a number of initiatives
actually started
uh and you know again it all gets mired
down into the business model
uh i know for a fact that you know
jpmorgan chase has started something
exactly like that
um swift has their own initiative around
something exactly like that
um and what's interesting is banks are
getting and of course i immediately it's
like oh i want to participate right just
because it's like
it's not directly related to what i do
but it is like sexy and interesting so
some aspects of like the kernel of being
like a nerdy engineer
um never truly leave you um but
we are so the answer is we're close to
having services like that
actually we're not just disclosed
services like that are in beta now
what now has to happen is the various
people have to
you know think about their position in
the market and how do they want to play
on somebody else's sandbox because
even though these things are open and
owned by nobody
uh you know they're still perceived to
have
you know my competitor is behind that
one do i want to play
but it is exciting and it is coming